ce qui m'a beaucoup étonné bizarre c'est
que le président de la république a
déclaré nous n'allons pas testé toutes
les françaises et tous les français ça
n'aurait aucun sens
or c'est exactement ce que préconise sur
ms depuis le début c'est ce que font les
pays qui ont mieux réussi que nous il
teste justement tous leurs
ressortissants
et ça a l'air d'avoir du sens alors
qu'est-ce qu'il avait mal compris
alors je pense c'était la deuxième
option je vais parler que de la balade
deuxième option de l'interprétation
qu'on peut avoir à partie moment on se
dit on sait que la bonne stratégie c'est
celle qui est que conte mis en place les
allemands et les coréens mais nous
sommes nous avons une stratégie qui est
guidé par la pénurie c'est à dire que
nous ne sommes pas en mesure puisque le
chef de l'état a pas fait allusion à nos
capacités de pouvoir réaliser ces tests
sérologiques donc malheureusement on
peut craindre mais moi je pense qu'il
vaut mieux plutôt avoir imposé la bonne
stratégie proposée la bonne stratégie et
faire en sorte que ne l'est qui a un
espèce de plan marshall pour qu'on
arrive avec l'arsenal suffisant pour
mettre en place cette stratégie plutôt
que d'abandonner un petit peu par
pénurie de moyens nous sommes quand même
la sixième puissance du monde nous
sommes une des pluies une d1 des pays
sur le plan pharmaceutiques les plus les
plus expérimentés avec d'énormes
capacités
donc elle avait bien sûr il faut tester
massivement dès les premiers signes avec
des tests pcr et testé massivement la
population pour savoir exactement quelle
est la part de cette population est
immunisée c'est ce qu'ont fait les
autres qui ont réussi
[Musique]